[Aplausos]
[Música]
Bienvenidos a diario del mundial el
programa de France 24 donde actualizamos
y analizamos el día a día de la copa de
la FIFA
Qatar 2022 a continuación nuestros
titulares
la selección de Ecuador consiguió
sacarle un punto a la representación de
Países Bajos y sigue Invicta en Qatar
los de la mitad del mundo buscarán
sellar su clasificación en la última
jornada del grupo a cuando enfrenten a
senegal
Irán se repuso de una marca derrota ante
la selección de Inglaterra y cobró
venganza venciendo a gales con marcador
de dos goles por 0 el resultado les pone
en carrera por la clasificación y deja
la escena servida para el cierre frente
a Estados Unidos
la dirección médica de la selección
brasileña confirmó una lesión en el
jugador Neymar Junior y ahora el Astro
de la selección y el París Saint Germain
podría volver en octavos de final
queratité para el partido frente a Suiza
tenemos análisis
y para analizar el acontecer de cada
jornada Contamos con la presencia de
Octavio saso periodista de la emisora
radial Blue radio en Colombia bienvenido
Octavio Hola Luis Buenas tardes Un gusto
saludarte También aprovecho para darle
la bienvenida a nuestra enviada especial
en
Qatar Natalia Ruiz quien nos trae todos
los detalles de primera mano de lo que
ocurre en esa nación Saludos Natalia
Hola muy buenas noches para ustedes
y así comenzamos con esta jornada
Ecuador preocupó a la selección de
Países Bajos el conjunto que dirige el
argentino Gustavo Alfaro mostró
personalidad Y capacidad para darle
vuelta a un marcador adverso y termino
sacando un punto en su partido frente a
la selección de Países Bajos que por
cierto no fue ese monstruo del que se
hablaba como equipo europeo y que iba a
dominar plenamente este grupo vamos a
acatar con Natalia Natalia un placer
nuevamente saludarte pero qué
sensaciones deja este equipo de Ecuador
pues deja unas excelentes a sensaciones
sobre todo porque este era el
contrincante más difícil a que tenía en
este grupo de Ecuador por supuesto las
cosas todavía no están finalizadas pero
ya las cosas pues se han mostrado
bastante bien sobre todo porque llegó un
gol muy tempranero por parte de los
holandeses en el minuto 6 apenas
el segundo tanto que marca este jugador
en este mundial y finalmente Ecuador no
bajó la cabeza no es de se desorganizó
no estuvo Digamos como haciendo siendo
prisionero un poco de los nervios sino
que fue buscando poco a poco la manera
primero de tomar la posición de la
pelota y eso fue lo que ocurrió porque
sobre todo en el primer tiempo en los
primeros 25 minutos se vio a Franky de
John que era el hombre clave de este
equipo holandés era a través de él que
pasaban todas las pelotas los pases
quien distribuía y finalmente los
Ecuatorianos fueron encontrando poco a
poco como poder
realmente quitarle la pelota a los
holandeses y eso fue lo que sucedió
sobre todo en el segundo tiempo cuando
ya llega ese tanto maravilloso de Enner
Valencia que coreó ese estadio y luego
mantenieron la presión mantenieron la
posición de la pelota y eliminaron todos
esos esfuerzos que quiso hacer este
equipo de Luis bangal para poder ganar
este partido y pues es toda la gran
dificultad para la Orange y muy buenas
sensaciones por parte de los
Ecuatorianos a pesar Pues de Enner
Valencia que tuvo que salir en camilla
ustedes saben él tiene una esguince en
la rodilla derecha dijo Después de este
partido en conferencia de prensa que
había salido que a lo largo del partido
había tenido dolor pero finalmente bueno
parece que es más la voluntad del
capitán de la actriz que pudo más para
poder salir adelante de este partido y
que espera estar en el próximo partido
que todavía le queda a la actriz aquí en
Qatar En todo caso por ahora en las en
la fase de grupos indudablemente que en
el Valencia
gran amuleto pero Octavio hablamos de
Luis van gaal ese seleccionador que
extiende su invicto en copas del mundo
pero que esta selección de Países Bajos
No termina de convencer pareciera que le
faltan argumentos para hacer ese gran
equipo que fue en otras copas del mundo
Sí sí evidentemente Luis tiene tiene
mucha jerarquía porque tiene jugadores
de gran nivel jugadores que normalmente
están en las mejores competencias del
mundo Jugando Champions con clubes
realmente importantes Pero a este equipo
le falta eso ser un equipo convertirse
en un equipo que pueda digamos dominar
las dos áreas del juego que sea capaz de
trascender Más allá de su potencia
individual y más allá de esa habilidad
que tengan algunos de sus jugadores
Países Bajos no no se le acerca ni
siquiera aquellos equipos arrolladores
de la pasado Landa que que en algún
momento le le podían pasar por encima
sus rivales simplemente con el hecho de
estar presentes en el campo a este
equipo le cuesta mucho sin embargo no
hay que descuidarse porque esa misma
jerarquía que tiene Países Bajos
pasar factura en un partido con apenas
un detalle pasó en el primer juego un
detalle le permitió a Países Bajos a
dueñarse de del duelo de su primer
partido en el Debut y en este segundo
más allá del empuje de Ecuador Países
Bajos tuvo la posibilidad de haberse
llevado los tres puntos entonces me
parece que todavía le falta este equipo
de Luis van real convertirse en un
equipo para ser pretendiente real de
esta copa del mundo recordemos que Luis
bancal está tomando las riendas
nuevamente de esta selección pero
retornando al tema de Ecuador esta
nación está sumida en una fiesta y
sueñan con mejorar su actuación dentro
de las copas del mundo donde solamente
acumula un pase en octavos de final y
eso fue en la copa de 2006 disputada en
Alemania pero veamos cómo están viviendo
esta fiesta del fútbol en Quito Ecuador
gracias al trabajo de nuestro
corresponsal en ese país Gustavo Ortega
[Música]
un empate que la fanática ecuatoriana
vivió con emoción y angustia el partido
de la actriz contra Países Bajos los
Ecuatorianos se concentraron frente a
grandes pantallas Para apoyar a la
actriz a pesar de comenzar con un Golden
contra la emoción se hizo sentir en el
país andino Y eso nos va a servir para
sumar en el siguiente encuentro y vamos
a hacer el primero de este grupo pero no
faltó la copa mineralista en un país que
sueña con hacer historia en el mundial
2022 la copa la copa vengo con la copa
porque está la ilusión que tenemos todos
los Ecuatorianos llevarnos la copa Somos
la sorpresa del mundial y vamos por la
copa pero la afición mundialista también
llegó hasta las instituciones educativas
el gobierno ecuatoriano ha permitido que
los estudiantes puedan ver a su
selección de fútbol desde las aulas de
clases si estos encuentros se
desarrollan en medio una jornada laboral
docente el Ministerio de Educación
autorizó las unidades educativas
actividades para que los estudiantes
pueda calentar a su selección una vez
concluido el evento deportivo retomar
las actividades los docentes también
fueron convocados a respaldar
mundialista has desarrollado proyectos
educativos se acelerar los valores
deportivos en medio está justa
mundialista es que esta tercera ocasión
que el paisandino se enfrenta Países
Bajos la primera en marzo del 2006 la
segunda en mayo 2014 y ahora en un
mundial 2022
definitivamente un bonito gestos del
gobierno ecuatoriano en permitir que los
estudiantes se enrumben y apoyen a la
selección de Ecuador pero la jornada
comenzó muy temprano con el Duelo entre
Irán y la representación de gales los
iraníeses consiguieron un nuevo triunfo
en una copa del mundo venciendo a la
escuadra de Gareth Bale y Compañía
Octavio otra selección asiática que
consigue un buen resultado esta vez
venciendo a gales dos goles por 0 Más
allá de la situación que se presentó al
final del partido gales termina con 10
jugadores Pero en cuanto a los equipos
de Asia están viviendo un buen momento y
esto se traducen que en preparación en
trabajo lo veremos en el futuro ya de
cara al Mundial de 2026 seguramente Luis
seguramente digamos el fútbol lo ha
cortado distancias eso no es un lugar
común en el día en el día de hoy hemos
visto en esta copa del mundo que las
diferencias realmente son muy pocas Más
allá de la goleada que vivimos de
Inglaterra o de la goleada que vimos de
España la realidad no representa eso
cada vez los países están más cerca cada
vez los países digamos tienen mayor roce
internacional esta selección de Irán
tiene jugadores en equipos importantes y
realmente hoy Irán y el equipo de Carlos
queiroz se quitó un peso de encima de
Luis por el hecho de estar batallando
también con el tema político con todo el
tema país que tienen alrededor y que
prácticamente para muchos de sus
nacionales son héroes Más allá de
jugadores de fútbol Entonces el partido
comenzó incluso con un gesto cantando el
himno que no lo habían hecho en el
partido anterior y aprovecharon
fundamentalmente y en la parte
futbolística el momento en el que gales
les regala el partido con esa
posibilidad de quedarse con 10 jugadores
Irán aprovechó ese detalle como para
marcar la diferencia yo creo que a
partir de de Y esa Victoria y más allá
de lo que sucede aquí en adelante en el
mundial
representa el bloque asiático un
movimiento muy interesante en función de
competir con las potencias del fútbol
mundial para mí no No yo no yo no le
pongo el Monte de sorpresa Japón por
ejemplo Japón viene trabajando hace
muchísimo tiempo y ha logrado resultados
importantes en los últimos campeonatos
del mundo Entonces Esto va generando un
movimiento y ese movimiento hace que hoy
Más allá de ese Mote de sorpresa sean
una realidad y creo que si nos vamos un
poco más atrás las eliminatorias en Asia
Estuvieron muy muy cerradas Que
prácticamente se definieron en las
últimas jornadas y precisamente hablando
del cierre de la jornada de este día
viernes las elecciones de Inglaterra y
Estados Unidos se repartieron puntos al
pactar sin goles un resultado que a
simple vista favorece la selección
inglesa que llega a cuatro puntos y
además cuenta con un mayor diferencial
de goles a favor pero deja Estados
Unidos con la obligación de ganar en su
partido frente a Irán donde antecedente
que se remonta a 1998 no es nada
alentador pero Natalia qué podemos
hablar de este compromiso por un lado
viendo el esfuerzo que hizo Estados
Unidos que por momentos llegó propuso
inquietud pero que al final no levantó
para conseguir vulnerar la valla del
conjunto inglés
Así es pero un excelente esfuerzo el que
hizo el equipo dirigido por Greg hater
finalmente tratando de parar todos los
ataques por parte de los ingleses un
poco como sucedió también en el partido
entre Países Bajos y Ecuador pues es a
partir de más o menos la mitad del
primer tiempo en que los estadounidenses
van logrando quedarse cada vez más con
la pelota y finalmente los ingleses
simplemente tienen uno que otro ataque y
es allí donde solía supremamente
peligrosos por supuesto tienen a Harry
kane hay una jugada sobre el minuto 26
donde están los ingleses que llegan ahí
con muchísima presión con muchísima
peligrosidad Pero por supuesto Estados
Unidos también tiene a policías un
excelente jugador el 10 de ese equipo
que también pues le daba esa parte
incisiva y ofensiva a este equipo pero
lo interesante de los Estados Unidos son
sobre todo esos laterales que
permitieron digamos poder defender
muchísimo más su cancha Y además de esto
hay que hablar del Arquero
estadounidense Turner que estuvo
fantástico salvando al menos tres o
cuatro ocasiones a su equipo por
supuesto pues no lograron ese gol les
fue completamente negado a pesar de que
de los esfuerzos que hicieron e incluso
ya al final del partido Pues fue más
Inglaterra en la que estuvo muy cerca
fue Harry ese cabezazo que finalmente
pues se va desviado Así que es un buen
esfuerzo por parte de los Estados Unidos
que de todas maneras en los 10 partidos
que ha disputado en su historia en los
mundiales de fútbol ante ante equipos
europeos pues nunca ha podido ganarles
Así que sigue un poco por esa misma
racha Pero el día de hoy pues es un buen
esfuerzo efectivamente por ahora Pues
habrá que ver el próximo partido Ahí va
a ser difícil ese partido entre Estados
Unidos e Irán Por supuesto que sí
Octavio hablar un poco de lo que podría
hacer entonces ese partido también el
frente a gales por parte de Inglaterra
rivales que se conocen muy bien muchos
jugadores del fútbol o que conforman la
selección de gales forman parte también
de Clubes tanto de primera segunda y
hasta Tercera División en el fútbol
inglés que podríamos esperar de este
partido eso esos dos partidos incluso
este de Estados Unidos Irán tiene una
rivalidad histórica política Que
obviamente está sobre la mesa y el
Inglaterra gales es prácticamente un
partido de un mismo país
digamos son jugadores que incluso muchos
de ellos tienen la posibilidad o han
tenido la posibilidad de jugar en ambas
elecciones o jugar en la selección de
Irlanda jugar en Escocia es decir
evidentemente se conoce No no va a ser
digamos un un partido desconocido para
ambos y eso quizás permita ver digamos
un partido más llamativo porque Vimos a
Inglaterra golear muy cómodo muy
tranquilo pero cuando le pones enfrente
un equipo como los Estados Unidos que no
lo deja manejar la pelota que que le va
enfrente que lo complica que tiene mucho
talento individual Inglaterra volvió a
pasar los mismos problemas con los que
llegó al mundial Y seguramente frente a
gales se va a encontrar con un rival
similar al juego que propone Inglaterra
Más allá de que el talento lo tenga el
equipo inglés y no lo tenga el equipo yo
creo aquí Luis que la diferencia va a
estar en el estado anímico de ambos
Inglaterra llega sabiendo que tiene
cuatro puntos que va a ser muy difícil
que lo saquen del medio y de la próxima
fase a cambio vale se ha recibido hoy un
baldazo de agua fría que no sé si se
puedan levantar Gareth Bale así después
del partido estamos realmente
destrozados y no creo que sea Inglaterra
el rival Tan sencillo como para que
gales pueda meterse en la próxima ronda
Así que que me parece que gales va a
quedarse en el camino y Inglaterra va
caminando a seguir rumbo a la próxima
fase de la copa del mundo y veremos Cómo
empiezan a manejarse los cruces con todo
esto que ha pasado en estos dos primeros
grupos que para muchos no estaba en los
papeles pero este viernes Se confirmó la
lamentable noticia sobre la lesión que
sufrió el jugador Neymar da Silva Junior
mejor conocido como Neymar quien se
perderá las próximas presentaciones del
pintacampeón por presentar una lesión
sufrida en el pasado partido contra
serbial también jugador del París Saint
Germain Presenta una lesión en el
ligamento lateral del tobillo derecho
confirmada por el médico del equipo
brasileño Rodrigo lasmar El galeno
también confirmó que Danilo Presenta una
lesión en el ligamento medial del
tobillo izquierdo Octavio sabemos de la
profundidad que tiene Brasil pero en el
aspecto mental Cómo puede afectar a un
combinado una situación como la que está
pasando Brasil en plena Copa del Mundo
Lamentablemente Luis yo creo que al que
más le afecta al propio jugador porque
Neymar ha tenido los mismos problemas en
las últimas dos copas del mundo es decir
él sabe que cada vez que piso un mundial
tiene una situación similar y esto
realmente lo debilita es a él más allá
de debilitar al grupo el grupo va a
jugar en función de ganar de seguir el
camino vienen de hacer un muy buen
partido eso lo fortalece evidentemente
como como plantel porque se sabe en
superiores Porque se saben favoritos y
evidentemente el hecho de que no esté su
líder en la cancha les va a significar
un golpe Pero estoy seguro que Brasil
está acostumbrado a este tipo de cosas
Brasil sabe perfectamente que que lucha
constantemente contra los ri de Neymar
No simplemente contra los rivales de
Brasil Entonces digamos la amplitud que
tiene tite en el en el banco de los
suplentes no hay jugador que pueda
sustituir el talento de Neymar pero
Brasil tiene jugadores suficientes para
acomodar el equipo y poder jugar sin
Neymar e incluso sin Danilo de todas
maneras habrá que ver cómo ASUME el el
juego el control del juego Brasil sin su
máxima estrella y en función de eso Si
Brasil puede sacar los tres puntos para
estar tranquilos y esperar que vuelvan a
Neymar ya en octavos de final va a ser
un gran paso para ellos y cómo podríamos
pensar siendo directivos del París Saint
Germain en este caso que sabemos que el
presidente está presente en en Qatar
ante esta situación el jugador
preferiría jugar estos últimos partidos
con la Selección de Brasil lo prefería
descansar porque en Enero ya se reactiva
una liga estupe estrictamente complicada
como lo es la francesa lo que pasa Luis
cuando tiene un jugador de la jerarquía
de Neymar ahí nadie nadie puede meterse
en realidad a Neymar nadie le va a
cortar el sueño de seguir jugando la
Copa del Mundo ni su equipo ni ni la
selección era lo que decía por ejemplo
Gustavo Alfaro antes del partido de hoy
de Ecuador ahí en el Valencia no lo
puedo sacar porque no hay manera de
hacerlo y igual la jerarquía Neymar va
por lo mismo lo que yo sí creo Es que
tanto el presidente del París Saint
Germain como el técnico como la gente
del club que está en el mundial saben
perfectamente de la fragilidad de Neymar
y entienden perfectamente que es el
juego el brasilero fue fue muy duro la
verdad la forma en Cómo Serbia trató a
Neymar y era prácticamente evidente que
Neymar iba a terminar o golpeado o con
alguna lesión Ahora hay que dejarlo
tranquilo que él pueda reanimarse volver
anímicamente Y si puede volver para
octavos de final y jugar va a ser mucho
mejor para el psg y también para el
espectáculo pero a continuación vamos
con una selección de noticias
previo al juego entre gales e Irán una
fanática de la selección de Irán sostuvo
una camisa mencionando a máxima mini la
joven que murió cuando se encontraba
bajo la custodia de la policía moral en
Irán
las inversiones sauditas podrían
extenderse en el fútbol inglés durante
una conversación con el medio británico
PVC el ministro Saudita de deportes
informó que su país respaldará las
ofertas auditas para adquirir los clubes
Manchester United y Liverpool ambos de
la Premier League
[Música]
Lebron James reaccionó a los comentarios
sobre un jugador de la representación de
camelún que se muestra parecido a él se
trata de Brian bebo jugador que
participa en el Prime Ford de Inglaterra
de lebrón quien ha estado fuera por una
lesión respondió tengo que hacer cosas
en todos lados esto a los comentarios de
un fanático que reaccionó al jugador
cameronés y relacionó la presencia de
este y la ausencia del jugador de los
Lakers
de esta manera llegamos al final de
Diario del mundial por el día de hoy
continúen con más de la programación de
France 24 y también France 24.com
[Música]